guys this may be the last time all of
our old Avengers friends get together
for a trailer that we can pick apart for
hidden little secrets and easter eggs do
you realize that let's finish this video
and maybe find a nice closet to cry in
for 20 minutes or something
whatever it takes just as Kevin Feige
promised our latest look at Avengers and
game is heavy on the drama and light on
the details but a few things definitely
jumped out at us ant-man uses a pencil
as a pole vault okay that's not an
easter egg it's just really cool but
okay let's just let's get to the more
subtle stuff we get some flashbacks to
the greatest hits of our main Avengers
Trinity Tony Steven Thor and here's some
voiceover from caps old flame Peggy
Carter hey this movie supposedly
involves time travel so maybe he'll take
the quantum realm back to the 40s and
meet up with her again I mean who would
even know I mean except Doctor Strange
he would definitely know in a later
scene we see Hawkeye training a young
woman presumably his daughter in archery
this has led to a lot of fan speculation
online that endgame may be planning to
kill off Clint and make his daughter the
new Hawkeye in his place in the comics
young lady Hawkeye is a woman named Kate
Bishop but I wouldn't put it past the
head honchos at Marvel to swap them out
for dramatic effect plus there's this
shot which looks like a very confused
Scott Lang returning from the quantum
realm trying to piece together what
happened in his absence if this is his
native San Francisco it looks like
there's been a pretty significant time
jump since he's been gone with
everything overgrown and returning to
nature that might also explain all the
new hairstyles maybe it's been years and
the world really has moved on rumors and
speculation online have indicated it
might be as much as five years since we
last saw the Avengers and Peter Parker
survived the snap he'd be in grad school
by now that would also give Tony Stark
and nebula a chance to make it back to
earth from deep space which they
obviously do because we see them here
United with their fellow Avengers we see
rocket teaming up with war machine they
both have new armor here on Rockets is
apparently based off his outfit from the
2008 reboot of the comics check out this
shot where the Avengers Assemble for
maybe the last
time these fancy red white and gray
suits are definitely a fashion statement
but it's likely they're also designed to
protect our heroes in the quantum realm
which they're using to go back in time
we assume to stop the mad Titan and of
course finally we're all freaking out
about seeing Captain Marvel and Thor the
two most powerful Avengers meeting up
for the first time please note the doors
still using his fancy not quite fan o
skilling axe Stormbreaker and also that
Carole either has really excellent
reflexes or no reflexes well we've
reached it this video's endgame if you
saw some amazing stuff in there that we
missed hit us up with a comment and let
us know and remember always aim for the
head like always
come on let's let's not make this
mistake again
you